foreign
hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel in this session we will
be learning the Tableau expert full
course let's have a look at the agenda
for today's session first we will learn
what exactly is W followed by that we
will understand the data connections
provided by Tableau then we will learn
how to create data extracts using
Tableau moving ahead we will understand
the Tableau calculations aggregations in
Tableau creating quick table
calculations box and viscous plots Etc
next we will learn each and every single
type of charts available in Tableau then
we will move ahead into formatting and
annotations in Tableau then we will
understand how to filter data entirely
followed by that we have organizing and
simplifying data in Tableau next we will
understand how to run mapping in Tableau
then we have the data blending data
sorting special field types promoting
data paths parameters intervaling then
we will understand the level of detail
expressions in tab value finally we we
will enter the most important segment of
the Tableau course that is the W
dashboard after understanding open our
skills to test users
and
finally
we will look through some more
frequently asked about receptional icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn this is bad then started a store
that sells automobile parts like brakes
exhausts tires lubricants and car
Interiors he made a good start with his
business and achieved profits however as
days passed by along with his growing
business he faced some business
challenges he received orders from a
variety of customers with different
needs and requirements for example the
northern states had higher demand for
performance parts than others in the
eastern states demand
Farms
truck parts
with the unbalanced requirements and
economy variations Ben had a tough time
helping his customers with products on
demand
he slowly realized he needed something
new that can help him tackle the store's
problems
what if Ben had a tool that could keep
track of his store's inventory and cells
a geographical map that can recognize
the demand for various types of products
from different regions
a forecast feature that could predict
the economic fluctuations in the market
and help them visualize every single
detail visually on one single dashboard
this software could practically solve
many business problems and also could
identify new opportunities to improvise
and grow the business
such types of software tools are called
business intelligence tools and one such
tool is Tableau Tableau is capable of
learning the store's business patterns
and running queries against the data to
help visualize the flaws and resolve
them quickly now let us understand how
Ben used Tableau and solve the issues
related to his business bin collected as
store's entire sales data from the
previous quarter and ingested it into
tablet Now using Tableau Ben was able to
categorize the data based on monthly
sales it took the daily sales and
considered it as the x-axis and then
Tableau computed the sales in the store
now then clearly understood the products
that outperformed the sales charts and
the products that did not have much
demand let us elaborate a little Ben
found that the performance parts like
sports exhaust turbochargers and engine
management systems were selling well
with the Tableau forecast feature Ben
identified the demand for Performance
Products in the next quarter so he
raised the prices on a few products that
had the peak demand and earned higher
profits in the second forecast report
Ben found no significant elevation nor a
drop in the demand for the tractor parts
and lubricants apart from this Ben saw
the sales graphs of electronics
encountered a drop in the current
quarter compared to the previous quarter
in the sales of electronics like the
music and infotainment systems were low
to improvise and stabilize the
fluctuating sales of electronics Ben
came up with some exciting clearance
sale offers on electronic products using
table's geographic map feature then
understood the product demand at a
regional level he found the northern
regions were interested in performance
kits for their imported sports cars the
Eastern regions at Goodman for truck
parts and lubricants using Tableau Ben
could generate various visualizations
based on his data and come up with
business oriented decisions
last but not least Ben could also
monitor his decisions and was able to
make some necessary modifications to his
business model on the go Ben is now
delighted as working with Tableau is a
smooth and efficient process today
Tableau is being recognized as one of
the best in class business intelligence
tools because of its powerful and
dependable features Tableau can support
and connect to a wide variety of data
sources like the cloud dbms Excel sheets
and even get connected to real-time data
from websites and Bin keeps his
customers happy using Tableau to solve
its business problems today more and
more leading business organizations are
leaning towards business intelligence
tools intending to improve their
business
upon quite a success in his business Ben
decided to get a detailed understanding
of Tableau by enrolling in simplylearn's
Tableau training program which is led by
industry experts who can train him
according to the current business and
I.T standards to make his business even
more successful so what is w
so before we understand what exactly is
that I believe let us imagine a simple
situation imagine that you are an office
worker and you get some loads of data
maybe like millions of rows or billions
of rows and you are supposed to extract
the insights of that particular data so
what do you do you basically load that
data into a database and try to write
the SQL commands and then try to extract
the insights of that particular data
so this kind of approach is basically
time consuming and you get exhausted now
what if you had a tool which could write
all the SQL commands for you in the
background and all you had to do is just
to drag and drop the data
sounds interesting right
so Tableau is just the same all you have
to do is just drag and drop the data and
it will automatically write all the SQL
commands you ever wanted to write on
that particular data and it will give
you live data interactions and advices
for the future
now with this let us understand the
definition of w so basically Tableau is
a business and analytical software tool
developed in America W helps people to
understand visualize and make data
driven decisions in real time with
extreme agility and accuracy
now with this let us continue with the
next topic which will be about the
various versions of w so at first we
have the Tableau desktop so Tableau
desktop is a data visualization
application to facilitate you to examine
virtually any kind of structured data
and generate highly interactive
beautiful graphs dashboards and reports
within minutes once a quick installation
you can tie to virtually any data source
from spreadsheets to data warehouses and
display information in several graphic
perspectives designed to be easy to
utilize you'll be working more rapidly
than ever before next we have the W
server it is a business intelligence
application that offers browser-based
analytics anyone can utilize it is a
rapid fire alternative to the slow pace
of traditional business intelligence
software it is an online solution meant
for sharing Distributing and
collaborating on content created and W
what makes W different it is proposed to
everyone there is is no scripting
required so everyone can grow to be an
analytics expert you can grow your
deployment as you require it
train online for free find answers and
minutes and not in months that's the
specialty of w
now followed by the W server we have W
online
so Tableau online is a business
intelligence application that offers
browser-based analytics anyone can
utilize as discussed before it is a
rapid fire alternative to slow pace
traditional business intelligence
software so Tableau online is a secure
cloud-based solution for sharing and
collaborating on Tableau view views and
dashboards next up we have the Tableau
public
so now I want to give you guys a serious
heads up if you're a beginner in w w
public is like an open source whatever
the data you choose to work on using
table Republic it goes to public so kind
of like Tableau public is not preferable
if you want to work on your company's
sensitive and confidential data W public
is a free software to facilitate anyone
to get connected to a spreadsheet or a
file and create interactive data
visualizations for the web
it is delivered as a service that
permits the user to be up to and running
overnight where table Republic users can
construct amazing interactive visuals
and publish them quickly without the
help of programmers or ID
it is designed for organizations to
facilitate their websites with
interactive data visualizations there
are higher limits on the size of data
you can work with and among other
features you can keep your underlying
data hidden and lastly we have W reader
W reader is a free desktop application
that you can use to open and interact
with data visualizations built in
Tableau desktop web tab new reader you
can filter drill down and discover
humongous loads of data now moving ahead
we have the features of w
so these are the few important features
that you might want to consider
those are the first one robust security
table you take special care of data and
user security it has a foolproof
Security based authentication and
permission systems for data connections
and user success
W also gives you the freedom to
integrate with other security protocols
such as active directory Kerberos Etc an
important point to note here is that the
W practices low level filtering which
helps in keeping the data secure
followed by that we have the
collaboration and sharing feature tabli
provides convenient options to
collaborate with other users and
instantly share data in the form of
visualizations sheets dashboards Etc in
real time it allows you to securely
share data from various data sources
such as on-premise on-cloud hybrid Etc
instant and easy collaboration and data
sharing helps in getting quick reviews
or feedback on data leading to a better
overall analysis of it another extremely
useful feature of tab W is the use of
Time series and forecasting easy
creation of trend lines and forecasting
is possible due to tablets powerful
back-end and dynamic front-end you can
easily get data protection such as a
forecast or a trend line by simply
selecting some options and drag and drop
operations using your concerned fields
next up we have live and in-memory data
Tableau ensures connectivity with both
live data sources and data extraction
from external sources as in memory data
this gives the user the flexibility to
use the data from more than one type of
data source without any restrictions you
can use data directly from data source
by establishing Library connections or
keep that data in memory by extracting
data from a data source as per their
requirement
tablely provides additional features to
support data connectivity such as an
automatic extract refreshes notifying
the user upon live connection fail Etc
next we have informative View and even
the mobile view one of the key features
of Tableau and the one that got its
popularity is its wide range of
visualizations in W you can make
visualizations such as bar chart pie
chart Gantt chart bullet chart motion
chart tree map box plot and many more
like you name it w got it you can select
and create any kind of visualizations
easily by selecting the visualization
type from the show me tab apart from
that it is capable to represent data in
mobile view as well table view
acknowledges the importance of mobile
phones in today's world and provides the
mobile versions of Tableau app the next
and the last feature is that being
capable of accessing data from various
kinds of data sources W offers a wide
range of data source options where you
can get connected and frustrated from
data sources ranging from on-premise
files spreadsheets relational databases
non-relational databases online cloud
data for data warehouses and many more
so followed by the features now we'll
discuss about the advantages of w
so following are the advantages of using
Tableau first one it has remarkable
visualization capabilities of course the
unparalleled capabilities of visualizing
information is on top of the list of tab
values software benefits followed by
that we have the ease of use the tools
intuitive manner of creating graphics
and a user-friendly interface allows
non-developers to utilize the basic apps
functionalities to the fullest users
arrange raw data into catchy diagrams in
a drag and drop way which facilitates
information analyzing and eliminates the
need for the help of IT department and
patent building
next high performance apart from its
high visualization functionality users
rates its overall performance as robust
and reliable the tool also operates fast
on big data which makes it powerful
performance on an important point on the
list of the advantages of Tableau and
next is the mobile friendliness one of
our best advantages are the Cavalier
benefits is its efficient mobile
application which is available for both
IOS and Android it adds Mobility to
table users and allows them to keep
statistics at their fingertips as well
as supports their functionality that
desktop and online versions have
and finally we have a thriving community
and Forum W has a rich Community the
number of w fans who invest their
expertise and scarce in the community is
increasing rapidly business users can
beef up their knowledge on data
processing and Reporting and get many
useful insights in this community also
Forum visitors are ready to help settle
any user issues and also share their
experience
next up we have the disadvantages of w
the first major disadvantage is the high
cost the Tableau is not the most
expensive visualization software
especially compared to such business
intelligent Giants such as oracles and
IBM Solutions all the same the license
is quite costly for small and medium
companies which makes it one of the
considerable tablets disadvantages
next is the inflexible pricing W sales
team is not flexible enough to provide
case-by-case approach for their
customers ignoring the fact that each
company has its own a unique
requirements for visualization tool
package the W sales model requires
clients to purchase and extends license
from the start
as a result a lot of companies that use
W arrive at the conclusion that they
don't need all their license features
they would prefer to buying a set of
requirements and scale them if necessary
followed by that the next disadvantage
is poor after sales support on multiple
message boards users complain that W
software lacks proper after sales
maintenance if customer has software
performance problem the support team
does not settle the matter by
investigating the problems root and
eliminating it next we have the power bi
capability or the poor business
intelligence capability as previously
mentioned the tool provides
best-in-class information visual
interpretation however it lacks the
functionality required for a fully
fledged business intelligence tool such
as large scale reporting the building of
data tables and statistics layouts and
lastly the poor versioning only the
recent Tableau version support revision
history while for the older ones
software rolling back is impossible now
with the advantages and disadvantages
discussed let's move into the top
companies hiring the companies which are
desperately looking for Tableau experts
are Accenture ey PepsiCo Deloitte Wells
Fargo capgemini and many more
now let's discuss the humongous and
handsome salaries offered by this Tech
Giants
so according to Glassdoor the average
salary of a w expert in America is 82
000 grants and for a beginner it is
somewhere around sixty thousand dollars
per annum and at the highest rate it is
1 lakh ten thousand dollars per annum
similarly the average salary of a
tableau expert in India is 5 lakh six
thousand per annum and for a beginner it
is somewhere around Three lakh Sixty
thousand and and for a highly skilled
experienced Tableau expert the salaries
range from 8 lakh 75 000 per annum in
this session we will start with certain
exercises which we will perform in
Tableau in order to understand some
basic concepts
now in order to learn Tableau the basic
first step is to import a sample data so
in our case what we have done is we have
imported a sample Superstore which is in
Excel format a sample superstore.xl
which has three worksheets in it orders
people and returns so by importing this
data into Tableau first of all we will
create relationships between these
sheets in order to identify who all have
placed orders and how many people have
returned the orders we will do some
analysis on the orders placed by certain
set of people and Order returned by
certain set of people
now as we have imported uh the sheet we
will make certain joins so the first
step is to drag the orders
table the order sheet on the
relationship canvas here okay and you
can see the data sample data the first
100 rows over here
okay then now we need to create an inner
join with people stable between order
and people okay so if you see
it has automatically detected the field
names on which the inner join has to be
created so on the order side you have
region and on the right hand side which
is the people data you have also a
region okay so both these columns are
common and that's how we have made a
join between orders and people data
so if I close this box and go and check
the people's data
open
so see the region and the person these
two columns from the people table have
now been
joined with the orders table right so it
means that these are the orders in a
particular region which has been placed
by
in this region
all right
let me show you the sample Superstore
Excel file now this is the structure of
the file you have a sample list of
transactions basically the orders which
are placed by customers
across multiple regions
south west of USA South Region west
region then you have a list of order IDs
which have been returned so basically
the order ID in the returns sheet
matches with those orders in the orders
table
and then you have the people
sheet in which you have region
and a person associated with that region
the sales person associated with that
region okay so basically when we are
combining joining orders with people we
are joining that
which orders
belongs to which region and who is the
sales person associated with it so what
we have done over here is we have made a
inner join means all the orders should
belong to a particular region and that
region is in the people's sheet and then
in the second step
now we will make a
left join between returns and orders
not in a join we'll make a left join
between returns and orders and we will
make a join using the
order ID
foreign
[Music]
click on left
and
select order ID as the join column now
what does left join means left join mean
is that consider all the orders from the
orders table and only consider the
orders from the returns table which have
data means which are returned otherwise
show null for the order IDs which are
not returned so if you see this is the
these are the two columns from the
return statement and these are null
because this is relevant to the order
IDs which are not returned okay which
has been accepted by the customer but
these are the orders for which you see
data in the returned and Order ID column
it means that these have been written
now with these joins in place please
save your book and now we have our
relations created in the
um
in the Tableau now we are ready to
create certain reports and extract
certain kpis using this relationship
model
now we'll move to sheet1
okay
and first we will place
state
and person on the rose
sheet okay
then
I'll go to my
numbers and
put the profit or the super State per
person how much profit I am making as a
company okay this is my goal to check
Now sort by highest to lowest
so California is giving me the maximum
profit of 76 381 then New York then
Washington so this is the sorted order
in which I have
listed my profit in descending order
now I can also check what are the number
of orders
placed
and check the distinct count
foreign
out of the total orders of 127 okay so
this is the number of total number of
orders which have been returned for
California is 127.
it's 16 29 so the sorted order is as per
the revenue as per the profit and this
is the details of the orders which have
been returned per state
so if you see for connected for a Kansas
there are zero returns
so you can also extract data
foreign
ERS and identify new rows using order
date so as and when new data is being
added you can
refresh it now say extract
and now you can save this information
profit
by state
and click save so this is the extraction
of this particular report which is
possible in tableau
so this is the first exercise which we
have completed for
reviewing and analyzing the profit per
state highest to lowest and within that
per state what are the number of
orders which have been returned by all
the customers the distinct count of
order IDs which have been returned
now let's start our second exercise on
creating calculated fields in tableau
now in this exercise we will be doing
certain
activities like we will be creating a
set to show the states which have more
than 100 customers then we will be
creating a calculated field to show an
average sales per customer okay then we
will create a calculated field to show
the sales goals and then show emerging
and developing stage so these are the
four kpis which we have to derive
now the first thing we have our sample
Superstore data already imported and the
relationships created in a join with
people and left join with returns
now we have our sheet 2 in which we will
create the states a list of states which
has more than 100 customers
so what we have to do is we have to
click right click on the customer name
and click create set
okay
now we have to give the name as states
with 100 plus customers
and then go to the condition tab
select by field
and then apply condition as
count of customer name
greater than equal to
100
and click
ok
now we have this set created states with
100 plus customers
now to determine average sales by
customer we have to now create a
calculated field
so go to the analysis and click on
create calculate field
okay
now name it as
average
sales per customer
and now we will say average
we will use a
okay so we are saying that per customer
we are using a level of definition
function include which means that per
customer what is my average sales right
we've already used a function aggregated
function called average so we are saying
per customer give me the total and then
give me the average per customer so
we're going to click ok
now create another calculated field you
can also create from here
and name is as name it as sales goal
now in this we are going to type the
formula if
minimum
States
with 100 plus customers equal to true
then
sum of
sales
into 1.3
else
average sales per customer into
100 so me we are saying that
if
the customer belongs to the set of
states with 100 plus customers then the
sales Target should be
1.3 times the actual sales as of today
else it should be 100 of the average
sales per customer
now let's create another calculated
field which we call as
emerging
or developing state
if distinct count
of customer name
is greater than equal to 100
then
the state is tagged as developing state
else it is called as
emerging state
okay so we have now
three calculated Fields average sales
per customer emerging or developing
State and sales goals
now we will use this in our
reporting
so we will drag sales goal under the
columns
and then I'll drop my state
so now this is the statewise sales goal
depending whether the state has 100 plus
customers or not
then add your customer name
make the measure as count distinct
and make it as discrete
Okay so
if you see this
we have the count of customers per state
and the
the sales goal
for that particular state
and now
I'll put my sum of sales the total sales
which I want
which is there per state
now go to show me and select
this particular chart
bullet graph
now to bring sales goals to column right
click on the sales access and select
swap reference line fields
now from your left hand panel drag and
drop emerging or developing State on the
color panel
okay so a merging state is the orange
one and the developing state is the blue
one
and save the sheet as
developing and the emerging States
so if you see this it's an emerging
State because its count is less than the
customer count is less than 100
its sales goal is
57384 but the actual sales is one nine
five one one okay
so now this is a developing State its
count is greater than equal to 100 and
its sales goal and its sales is exactly
the same it matches so that's why you
are saying the bar and the blue bar is
ending exactly where the vertical bar is
so what we are trying to depict is that
whether the state is going Beyond its
Target sales goal or it's behind it
and you can see that using this
particular vertical bar like for example
Michigan its sales goal is 71 952 but
its actual sales is seven six seven two
seven zero average sales so that's why
it is be above its Target
and it's a developing state
because it has more than 100 customers
so you can even sort
by the count of
the uh customers higher to lower so all
your developing state will grow from at
the top and the emerging States Will
Group at the bottom
or you can sort by
the sales goal
so the orange bar is the sales goal or
the blue bar so depending what sales
goal
has been
derived for each state
so let me now begin with connecting to
data now in this particular topic
we are at the end of this lesson you
will be able to
understand how you can connect to
Tableau Data server you will be able to
differentiate between a join and blend
how can you perform a join on a data how
can you blend a data we will discuss the
various connection options available we
will understand how tablet server Works
in terms of the code Ros authentication
all right we will understand various
performance optimization techniques as
well Shadow extra extract as well as
different methods that we can prepare in
terms of the data that we want to paste
on that you can perform the you can have
your connection to the database all
right so that's how you can connect to
the tablet server as well all right so
that's the very first basic so the
Tableau administrator is the one who
assigns the roles and creates these data
sources all right and you have uh
Tableau has the facility in order to
import different forms of data for the
analysis for your ease and once you're
connected to the Tableau server then you
need to select data root server data
source on the data menu you will need to
select a data source to download a local
file a local copy you can select and
create a local copy and then you can
also duplicate a duplicate of that data
source will be added up into your data
window so that's how you can connect to
Tableau server as well all right and it
basically promotes various features
wherein uh you can then connect to the
table server for your data so you are in
this example you can see that you're
able to connect to the table server as
an admin and connect to the sample
Superstore and it downloads it creates a
local copy and duplicate all the data in
that particular data window
that's how we can see the sample
throughput source and you can connect to
the server uh next we are going to also
understand what is joining and blending
so before I move on to the presentation
slides here what I'm going to do is I'm
going to move on to the environment
directly let us start exploring these
blending and joining features uh right
there in all right I'm going to simply
just clear all these sheets that we have
and
um let's go back to the connective data
source window all right now in terms of
uh this is where you're able to connect
you can see the Tableau server so it's
through the server that you can connect
within you can specify your server
credentials and you can click on connect
and uh based on that that's how then you
can provide the credentials and uh log
in all right now I do not have a server
or a connection where and I can show
that example but this is how you can
click on any of these servers you would
have to type in the URL click on connect
and then provide the usernames and login
provided and that's how you can connect
to your data source using a server
option all right I'm going to show you
the file option wherein you can connect
to an Excel and let us discuss the join
and the blending parture all right so
let me click on
it says we have the sample support uh
data store here and in this when I pull
in order all right I pulled in the four
sheets so there are three sheets in that
particular Excel file when we pull an
order this is how now you can identify
that whatever are uh these are the
header names these are the dimensions
and measures that's how it's getting
identified if you can notice all the
dimensions are first place you have all
your measures then you're able to
identify the data type and the role on
ABC which is a contextual value or
numeric value that means it's a
dimension with a pound sign what kind of
a data role is it established
automatically identifying each of these
rules as well all right even in the
metadata that's how you can see the
field names the field uh name that
you're going to see onto your page onto
uh your view and the table from which
it's going to be getting pulled in from
in this you can rename in case you want
to change the particular name hide it or
Alias it will describe it
all right so this is how you connect now
connections is where you have the option
to connect between knife and extract now
if you connect to live that's
interconnected to this particular sheet
live that means any update happening
onto your uh sheets any kind of updates
on the sheet there is a light connection
it will automatically update your views
as well onto your sheets that you're
creating and in case if you select on an
extract all right this is what it means
that it allows uh what it does is it it
Imports that data into the Tableau Data
engine first in the data engine where
it's going to perform these queries it
will create an extract and based on
these we can then start using the
connections all right so what it does is
it disconnects it's more like a small
extract more like a cube if you
understand it in that manner taboo
creates an extract of that file
providing you a disconnected whether it
allows you to give you a better
performance a better query
uh that's how you can then work on and
start creating uh and working on these
extracts so you can refresh these uh
extracts at a timely manner as well so
that is what the Tableau extracts are
but it extracts it as a copy of the data
uh and saves it in the engine and that's
how then the performance as well gets
better in terms of using where you can
connect to your particular data all
right so you can work with uh multiple
data sources data sources can be of any
type all right wherein you can edit from
the number of lists that you can see it
can be a flat file a server file as we
saw or the saved one and we can also
then join multiple tables within the
data or we can also blend when it's
coming in from different data sources
and we can also perform a blending so
let me first show you an option for
joints now you can see we have the order
table law when I drag and drop the
people uh sheet as well here you can see
that Tableau has automatically created
it or joint all right it has
automatically created a join when we
have pulled in two tables coming in from
the sheet and by default all right we
have the inner join that Tableau creates
so it creates an inner join here wherein
again you can then click on the join
option here and you can specify and
modify the join based on whether you
want it as a inner join which is a
default you want a left joint now if you
see the right join has been disabled
here okay I will show these options here
by default the right join is disabled by
uh Tableau by default by default and to
enable that you will have to uh connect
to your Excel sheet in a different
manner I will show that your shortly so
that's how you can change and you can
perform your joints this is where you
can uh explore and show The Joint cloth
and here again then you can specify like
you can see a join that's been created
amongst the data source which is region
and region people among these two data
all right it's also showing you the join
and whether it is uh equal to or not
equal to all right so you can connect to
multiple tables and uh based on that you
can add in tables you can specify the
different joints and based on that then
when you click on sheet uh you will then
be able to see that there is a joint
being performed there are two tables now
the people stable also that has been
added in and it has now performed and
you know joined on our data and you can
start using this particular option so
let's say I'm going to pull in the
region on my columns and I'm going to
have my phase onto my rows it's now
providing me uh details of my sales at a
regional basis now let's say I also want
to to analyze the people belonging to
these regions depending on the color so
it's going to change the colors based on
the central East South and West all
right that's how these are uh the people
the number of people belonging to each
region that it has identified so that's
how it has taken up the region people as
you saw there was a joint that was
created and it's giving us that
particular option and based on that you
can see here we just have uh this
particular data source here and that's
how you can see now I used it earlier as
well if you remember we had pulled in
one particular table hence the blue tick
mark sign here enables and shows us that
this is the primary data that's being
used now this comes in picture when
we're using a particular join so let me
right now just um uh use this particular
detail here and we're not going to
require this all right so let's just
close this we just need one right now
because casting on blending I'm going to
show you the blending part later right
now we're discussing on joints so uh
that's how you can join in your data
sources and you can combine multiple
Fields using these joints so when you
have when you have multiple tables you
can simply connect to the data let me go
back to the data source page uh this is
a startup page the data source page and
you can see the joints that's been
performed now let's say you want to
create a join where you want to force
due to certain situations and scenario
where you want to post or write out a
join all right or right join or for that
matter you want to write a custom
sequence now you're not able to write a
SQL right here in the in the drag area
pane where you can drag and drop your
sheets from the Excel file or any kind
of a file that you're connected to for
that uh and to enable the right join you
will need to uh connect to your data in
a specific manner so let me open up a
new instance of Tableau here
and let me show that to you as to how we
can enable the right choice and how we
can have our custom sqls as well so in
case if you want to write in a custom
SQL on our view then how can we perform
that initial custom SQL all right
okay so let us connect to our data here
and I'm going to take you on to the
Excel file now when I click on the
samples Super Store here okay uh what we
have done is we clicked on open and
that's how we opened up the uh file all
right and that's how we could see the
sheets now instead of using the open
option directly what I'm going to do is
in the drop down right here instead of
open we have an option that says open
with a legacy connection all right this
is what is going to enable us to write a
custom SQL where we can specify a query
rather than using the entire data source
or pulling in the entire table so quick
clicking on the second option in the
drop down in the open uh tab here you
will be able to see the open with Legacy
connection I'm going to uh so ensure
that you've selected that and that's how
you will then connect to the data source
and with that you now have a new custom
SQL option that's opened up for yours
this is where you can once you've
connected you can double click on the
new custom SQL and you can write in your
query you can write in the SQL where you
want to perform the query and pull in
your data all right you can have your
select from
and let's say
orders
all right so that's how you can perform
and you can write in a custom SQL and
you can pull in the required data you
can have your required table that you
can pull in in terms of creating a SQL
that you want to pull in and have your
data all right so you can have your
select from the
orders and
preview the results
so here you can see the order table has
nine thousand nine four row we have a
preview of the data available in that
particular uh sheet that we pulled in
all right and we can now parameters is
what I'm going to cover when we come out
to that particular topic so I'm going to
leave this for now so that's how you can
write your custom SQL and you can click
on OK and that's going to pull in your
entire data and as you can see now
instead in the earlier views I'm going
to just switch to the earlier instance
of Tableau you could see that you could
see the name of the table that I dragged
and pulled in you could see the name
order but in case when we write a custom
SQL then it gives us the name which is
written as custom SQL query all right
and this is where you can get the
information you can edit the query in
case you want to change the results and
requirements so that's how instead of
clicking on open you click on open
Legacy connection and you can have your
own custom SQL defined now along with
this all right when you open and when
you click on a legacy connection when I
drag in the people's table here you can
see that even the option for right
joints have now been enabled so by
default Tableau disables the option for
right join and in case in certain
situations and circumstances you want
the right join to be enabled you win in
the same manner have to import and
connect your data using a legacy
connection and you will have the right
join which is going to be enabled there
for you all so you can have your custom
sqls or the right joints in that case
which gets enabled and you can use a
custom SQL or a right join right so that
was custom SQL then uh joining is where
you can as I mentioned identify and
choose between the Clauses and the
Clause that you want to add in right now
let me show you an example of blending
as well so I'm again going to open a new
instance of tableau
all right and uh with that I'm going to
show you the example of blending so
let's say you have uh you want to join
in and when is the best time when is the
best way that you should use now joining
is when you have all your multiple
tables that you want to join coming in
from one data source blending would be
required when you want to join in uh
multiple tables coming in from different
data sources or for that matter you can
also blend even though the tables are
coming in from a single data source
there might be instances that you might
want to have still perform a blend
instead of a joint so let me show that
option to you all right so let me
connect to the data
let's connect to excel pull in our
sample Superstore file that we have we
have the order table all right and I'm
going to go on to these sheets here all
right so we have one order we have one
data which is the order table now I am
going to again click on add a new data
source coming in from the same Excel
file and this time I'm going to have the
people's table
and move to the sheet so now if you
notice we can see two uh data sets here
which is one for the orders and one for
people here and in here now this is
where the blending will will take place
this is where you will have a blend
automatically when you pull in a view if
there is a common view that comes into
picture now let's say I'm going to first
pull in the order date onto the columns
all right
and as soon as I pull in you can see
that my order table has now got a blue
check mark which has become a primary
data source all right and now let me
pull in sales onto my rules
and from people let me have
uh from the people's table let's have
region pulled in and add it to the color
so region has become a secondary data
set and now you can see a blend sign
right a linking a data blending that has
automatically been performed on both
these two data sets all right that we
have the order table and the people's
table blue being primary and people uh
which is being or secondary in this case
all right so that's how you can mention
now in terms of blending what happens is
you cannot specify the joints you are in
this case there is a primary and
secondary data and it is automatically
blending in the data for you it is
automatically pulling in uh the data you
will not be able to your select on the
kind of join you will not be able to
manipulate the joints so that's how even
though at times you have the same tables
that are coming in as I mentioned there
are times where you might want to
perform and change the joints so that's
when you can use the joining table
option that comes into picture so that's
the difference between your blending and
between joining the tables
right
so uh you can see this available link
and you can see how it was simple to
drag a particular View and pull in data
and your as well region has been added
to the color pin because of which the
Legends have been created identify all
four regions present in the data and
it's also letting us know here in the
marks that region is coming in from the
secondary table you can see the orange
ambotic marker and that's how you can
identify that region is coming in from
the secondary table that's been created
all right in terms of uh connecting as
well wherein you can combine and half
the joint uh enabled now depending on
the kind of data all right going back to
the data source depending on the kind of
tables and the kind of data that we have
that's when we can enable and have the
joints that we can decide on all right
so one is you would require and need to
have a multiple a legacy connection with
which you can then Define the right
outer joints all right and that's how
you can proceed and have additional uh
joints that you can work on
uh we also discussed how we could create
and connect to a custom SQL query all
right and uh that is how we could using
the Legacy connection uh also enable the
right outer join wherein we could then
perform a right join on our tables as
well all right and in case if it's a
query then it gives them the name of the
query uh as a custom query which is what
we saw onto the review and the extract
there all right now in terms of extracts
all right now extracts are basically
your saved subsets of the data source
which will help you in improving the
performance so instead of as I mentioned
instead of being connected to a live
connection it is better that we select
an extract which creates a subset and
stores it in the Tableau engine wherein
it performs the queries and it takes
advantage of this functionality where it
is not connected to the original data
source and with this it can actually
reduce the total amount of data in terms
of defining and limiting it so that's
how you can create an extract and let's
say uh once you've created an extract
you can then perform like I said you
have the edit option where you can edit
the additional detailing you can allow
an incremental fetch happening where
then you can refresh the data each time
or your data is updated you can provide
an information fair so this can help you
in improving your performance you can
take advantage of the functionality in
terms of the data source for using the
discounts or the distinct counts as well
and moreover it's more like an offline
mode you're actually accessing your data
as an offline access where it's not
directly connected and you're able to
use it like a data or local data all
right so that is the difference between
a live and an extract so that's how you
can make use of the Legacy connections
as well so let's go back to the
presentation slides and have a recap now
[Music]
um
these are the joining tables that's what
we discussed that in terms of the tables
that we have we can join our table and
we have various joints available where
it makes it easy for us to uh analyze
the data that we want to review we can
join to multiple tables and based on
that we can customize the inner the list
the right or the full outer join now the
full outer join also depends on the kind
of data source that you're connected to
all right so in case of an Excel file we
still do not have the right Auto join
option which is enabled so this possible
option again when you open with a legacy
depending on the data type is how you
will have the right Auto join that you
can pause and have it enabled so this
would be depending on the kind of data
source file also that you have and you
have these four join types that you can
use in terms of joining tables in
Tableau now when would you want to use a
join all right so uh a scenario is that
you have a sales manager of an online
shopping website and you want to analyze
the customers who have returned at least
half the number of orders that they have
placed now to fulfill this requirement
he will require a worksheet whereas he
can join the orders and the return
tables on a particular common Dimension
all right so that's how then we can
create a join we can change this between
uh the inner default to a left join
between the order tables and the return
tables and based on that he can then get
to know the customers who have returned
at least half the number of orders that
were placed all right
now in terms of enabling a right outer
joints uh this is taken care of by the
Microsoft jet data engine driver so in
case if you all are facing of trouble
where you're not able to connect and see
that particular option it's throwing an
error this Legacy connection options
comes in only when you're using a
Microsoft jet data engine driver this is
easily available in case if you do not
have it you can install this driver and
with this it will enable the right outer
joy and the custom SQL for us all right
to enable the uh right out of join here
that's how you open it with a particular
Legacy connection now in terms of a
write outer join we saw an example we
can force and use the right outer joint
we can select on a new custom SQL where
we can type in and have a custom uh SQL
generated
and that's how we can work on with the
SQL where we can provide the SQL syntax
and based on that the data source will
then be generated
now in terms of blending this is what
happens when you have multiple data
sources in your viewer when you want to
establish a link between them or you
want to blend your data uh it does not
create a row level joint so in case uh
like the example that we did also it was
coming in from the same sheets from the
same Excel file but we did not want to
create a row level join then that's when
data blending would come in handy you
can use it with a related data across
multiple sources that you want to
analyze in one particular view so that's
how you can blend your data which
creates a primary and a secondary data
so we saw that in this example uh you
can see that it is a customer segment
department and some of sales wherein the
bars are being created which are coming
in from the from the primary connection
but in terms of the sales plan all right
these sales plan are coming in from a
secondary data you can see the Amber
connection here the Android that is
allowing you to understand and segregate
and differentiate that it is a secondary
connection
so in Tableau that's how you can
identify as you saw that your primary
source and you have your secondary
source wherein you can identify and
distinguish you can distinguish between
the common fields that are present in
your data and you can establish a
connection in case if it has not
established a link you saw that there
was an automatic link then you can
provide a link Autumn uh by explicitly
defining a link as well let me take you
back to uh the environment
okay so this was the custom sequel
in this case in case if there is uh no
link provided then you can provide a
particular link onto your view you can
have the option if it has not enabled
then you can select your particular you
can see that uh it has not uh implicitly
defined but it's giving you an option
that there is possibility of linking so
you can explicitly Define you can click
on this link and use person as a linking
field and this is also linked in your
data with the previous data that you
have all right so that's how you can
Define and explicitly mention uh the way
that you can blend your data and you can
identify another way can also be wherein
you can edit uh the connection in the
mapping and that's where you can perform
so you can go back to your data sources
and you can explicitly Define you can
identify uh whether the First Source are
the names whether the rows your are
automatically generating a field or not
all right so that's how you can have
these two table use and you can Define
the blending whether you want it or not
you can disable the linking as well in
case you don't want to perform a
particular link
so uh with uh coming to that now let us
understand I've already discussed the
difference between the joints and length
and where you can use it so let's uh
have a recap again or in terms of
joining or joining is a SQL term wherein
is combining two data sources coming in
from a single data source while in terms
of blending it's more about combining
two different data sources into one
single sheet all right uh joining is
done once at the data source and this
can be used for every worksheet while
blending will be done individually for
every worksheet okay and both the tables
that are joined must must exist in the
SQL database while in blending it helps
us combine the database which is coming
in from different sources different
locations and in case if it's a
multi-dimensional source if it's a queue
then you cannot perform a joint and in
terms of blending you have a primary
source and uh but in in terms of a
primary source it cannot be your Cube
but your second resource can definitely
be a cube that you can use in terms of
performing a blend all right
so that's how you can optimize your
connections you can select whether you
want to have uh perform a blend on your
connections you want to perform a join
depending on the kind of connections
that you have and that's how you can
work with them with the different data
sources that you have available we're
going to proceed further in
understanding how we can create data
extracts all right so as I mentioned the
extracts are where you create a subset
of your data source you can extract a
particular data you can save it as a
subset which will help you in performing
and improving your query so instead of
the live you can simply click on the
extract which will create a tableau
extract for you all right
so uh let me just show you let me take
you to the uh repository and in that you
will be able to identify in my Tableau
repository data sources you can see that
uh we have a tableau extractor for World
indicator so what it's done is it has
created a subset of the word indicators
data source and it's created it's
disconnected it's an offline mode which
can allow us to improve the performance
it can be accessed offline as well when
you're away when you're probably
traveling and we can then create an
extract where we can keep refreshing it
with the original data and we can then
replace it with the content or we can
provide a complete incremental refresh
with these all right now extract can
also be created from uh within our data
sets as well once you've performed so
let's say let me go back to
uh view here and let's have
category in our columns let's have
quantity on our rules now even here you
have the option of going under the data
menu where you can uh click on the
extract data so whatever you've selected
any kind of performances and any kind of
the aggregations that you perform now
this is your uh data that you perform
now in instead of even though it's a
live connection you can still go to the
data menu here and you can click on
Create and extract the data which will
create a subset all right which will
create a subset for you where you can
create this data and you can provide the
different fields wherein you can select
what you want to filter whether you want
to add a specific filter to your field
whether you want to specify the
aggregation data for the visible
Dimensions this is where you can select
the option for the measures to be
aggregated uh the default instead of
using the default uh what is the kind of
aggregation that you want to use so this
can allow you to minimize the size of
your file as well and increase your
performance you can click on aggregation
and you want to roll up the dates to
your quarter to month you can select on
the aggregation
the number of rows that you want to
allow in terms of the incremental fetch
or you want to provide
the incremental fetch for all rows or
just the top particular selected rows so
you can select on that particular option
once you've specified all these
detailings you can then click on extract
and that's going to save the subsequent
uh file in the location that you have
saved in terms of the extract and it
will save up and extract for you all
right so when you click on extract it
will ask you for a subsequent location
of where you want to save it there is a
customs query that we have used and
let's say if we save it on the desktop
itself you can see the save type which
is a DOT pde which is a Tableau Data
extract and the next time you can start
working using these data extracts and
you can start performing where you do
not need to then have your custom SQL uh
written in or any other detailing you
can simply use the extract and start
working on it all right you can actually
uh restrict the size and improve the
performance and you can perform data
extract from these as well all right
foreign
option here you have the option to
replace your particular data source so
let's say you have your uh option where
you want to uh perform of or incremental
sets then you can replace the data you
can upgrade it or for that matter you
can go to this particular uh table you
can refresh your data with the uh
connection where you have the uh
additional refresh data you can view
your data you can duplicate it rename it
we uh just discuss how we can create the
extract data options as well so that's
how you can perform and see and and have
an extract
of your data so that was uh using your
data extract
now uh you can also write custom SQL so
you've discussed that let me take you
back to the presentation slide and have
a recap so here this is the window that
we saw in terms of the extract where you
can add in the qualifications where you
can narrow down your data even more
further you can select an incremental
search whether you want it for all the
rows or limit the number of rows to be
included in that particular extract uh
then we also saw that how we could write
a custom SQL we could open it in a
Legacy Collection that helped us to open
up a custom SQL window where we can
write down the SQL with the exact data
that we want to analyze this can again
help us in improving the query
performances where we can write down and
provide uh an optimized query against
our data that we want to use
all right uh in terms of the supported
data sources a lot of you all had
questions what kind of data sources are
supported now Tablo desktop is uh
supporting the uh it determines uh the
support depending on the kind of license
that you have purchased all right so
only when you have the required license
it will support the different data
source sites and you have a personal
Edition which provides you and allows
you to uh use the support for a lot of
databases uh but it is the professional
Edition that provides you additional
database options that you can connect to
so data such as text files access files
Excel sheets uh and so on these can be
connected through the personal Edition
while in terms of a professional Edition
the professional license this is where
you can connect other than the other
than the personal editions you can
connect to the personal uh additional
databases like your Oracle SQL and you
can connect to certain more additional
connections here which is supported 40
plus data connections which is supported
in the professional Edition all right so
that's how you can connect to these
different connections now
also along with that once you have your
server that comes into picture uh What a
server does is it provides you a curb
authentication which is a supported
trusted authentication or that it uses
in terms of your single sign-on all
right so what it does is in this case is
that uh as you can see it is a protocol
that is provided to trust the
authentication between your machine
and that's how uh it uses a third-party
network service called as the KDC the
key distribution center which provides a
secure connection between your desktop
and the flow machines and this is
supported based on the Kerberos
authentication all right and that's
where you can it handles in it uses only
one user authentication the permissions
and the access control uh in such cases
like the workbooks uh is is going to be
now these the workbooks and extracts
will not be handled by quadrons but uh
the permissions and access control those
are the things those are the detailing
that Ford Rush will be handling in terms
of your data connection
all right so basically if your taboo
server has a code block enabled uh on
your machine with a valid active
directory credentials then what Tableau
does is it connects to your server and
it completely skips the steps of
authenticating so in case let me take
you to the environment
you're in the environment you can see
the server option and in this you have
the published workbook now let's say
when you want to you've created your
workbook and you want to publish it onto
your server now this is where it asks
you to connect to the server here it
asks you to provide the credentials and
then based on that it then asks you once
you've connected to let's say you
connected to your server it is then
going to ask you a sign on for that
particular configuration now if you have
a word growth environment which is
activated then it's going to skip these
basic steps here and it will directly
allow you to connect and Skip these
connection uh that comes in in between
so that is what is called Ross
Authentication
right so it's a single sign-on method
and once you have that enabled then you
can make use of these you can you need
to configure your tablet server with
these curb Ross configurations all right
so it's a three-way Authentication
Protocol
now how this works is a mechanism of
mutual authentication between the client
and the server it's provided with the
curb Ross authentication so when the
Hugo user logs into the directory it
directly asks for the credentials which
are authenticated by fold rod and once
this is authenticated a ticket is
generated and sent to the user's
computer and then when the user tries to
connect to the Tableau server from the
desktop or the web browser the server or
the Tableau server authenticates the
user and it directly allows us to
perform now this mechanism is provided
before the network connection is opened
up between the client and the server
right
so how does it work in terms of a single
sign-on how does it support it is it
supports a single sign-on option wherein
uh you have the server configuration and
in this you have a core blocks tab where
you can uh Define enabling the single
sign-on option in terms of the
environment where you can connect uh
individually you can connect with a
single sign-on to connect to the server
from your desktop or the web browser all
right in terms of trying to optimizing
your query
now how can you optimize your query
Tableau adopts various query
optimization techniques to improve the
query performance all right so what it
does is it it provides parallel query
where it improves the performance speed
of the dashboard by performing and
providing the capability of executing a
parallel query so in this case what
happens is it executes more queries at
the same time it is independent uh
queries that start at the same time and
hence we are faster and improve the
performance so this is what Tableau does
it provides a parallel query next in it
has the query Fusion in this what it
does is Tableau has the ability to
reduce any kind of complex or large
number of queries into a pure simple one
so that's how it again optimizes your
performance right and then it also has
external query caching in this it
quickens up the process of optimizing
your data by processing it into a cache
all right so that uh it does not need to
go and hit in the warehouse every time
that you require a particular data so
this is possible with the external query
crashing so Tableau adopts these various
uh methods it also has a data engine
vectorization wherein it has a in memory
analytics column and it's a faster query
which helps in reducing the extract size
and creation time so based on these
that's how it can improve the
performance and that's how it optimizes
these techniques and Tableau handles and
takes care of each of these so it
performs The Parallel query by phone it
uses a particular query faction which is
short it does not uh it shortens up all
the queries the external query caching
that it uses and also provides a data
engine vectorization where it makes this
even more quicker and faster
now in order to Quicken the process of
your loading of data what Tableau does
is it creates a saves a shadow extract
file on its own all right what it does
is uh in the repository for you to load
your data faster other than you creating
an extract it takes up the content of a
shadow extract in your repository file
and it saves it up as a shadow while
you're working on the workbook all right
and that's where then when you're
creating and working uh based on the
Legacy non Legacy excels or text files
or statistical file it creates a shadow
extract file automatically wherever you
have your repository so in case when
you're working on something what it does
is in your repository folder all right
where you have your repository which is
in my documents in the data sources you
can you will be able to see that it
provides you a particular
uh extract that is or Shadow extract
that's been created and you can see that
uh it it creates a shadow extract right
there where you can make use of all
right or in the background so this is
done automatically by Tableau to Quicken
up the process this is something that
you do not need to handle uh by default
this uh the folder there is a folder
that gets created uh when you have a
proper licensed version then you will
see that in the repository folder you
will have a shadow extract folder and uh
based on that that is how uh you will
see that at least the first five at
least the top five Shadow extracts will
be uh save with the dot DT TTD extension
and that's how it uses and replaces it
replaces the oldest one so when you have
a license version in that case then
that's when you will be able to see this
extract folder and uh this is when it
quickens up the entire process let me
begin with the next topic which is
calculation all right
now in terms of calculations uh these
are pretty much or these help us in
terms of understanding in terms of
creating an extractful meaningful result
of our data all right so sometimes it's
pretty much necessary that we make use
of calculated fees now you've already
seen that I've been making use of we
created the ship to date and I created
various calculations and I've been
mentioning that uh you know I'm going to
discuss these in detail in the next
topic when we have like we created the
primary table the secondary table I
showed you the quick table calculation
so you're already pretty much aware of
how I was using them but let us
understand these in detail now all right
so let me begin to at the end of this
session in terms of when we complete
we'll stop it you're going to understand
how you can make use of spring dates
logical as well as arithmetic
calculations how you can work with
different aggregation options how you
can make use of the grand totals and
subtotals the quick stable calculations
which are inbuilt by Tableau how you can
create automatic and custom splits
discovering the ad hoc analytics which
is offered by Tableau and how you can
perform the LOD that is level of details
calculation all right so let's begin
with the very first topic how you can
work with strings 8 logical and
arithmetic calculations wherein you can
create a completely new field which is
not present as part of your underlying
data you can actually create that using
a specific formula there are functions
and operators provided so you can use a
string all right you can use a date you
can use logical operators or arithmetic
calculations and based on that you can
then apply certain functions and
operators and finally create a
calculation so you can create these four
kinds of calculations the arithmetic
State string and logical ones all right
so let us understand and explore how we
can use how Tableau provides us various
built-in functions wherein we can use a
calculated see and create an arithmetic
calculation so we've seen an example
where I created a profit margin or a
profit ratio in our earlier exercises in
our earlier demonstrations wherein you
can use let's say when you want to
create the profit ratio we use the sum
of profit divided by sum of sales so
that's how we created an arithmetic
calculation similarly we can create a
new string calculations all right so I'm
going to show you an example of each of
these uh and then we can also be sure
right now I created the date to ship in
the earlier example for one of our views
wherein I use the date calculation where
we created the date and we will also
make use of one of these logical
calculations to see and understand how
we can make use of the
is as The Logical calculation operators
and functions and make use of these
calculations so uh we have a scenario
here so before that let me move on to
our Tableau environment here right and
um
let me start showing you one of the
examples of each that we can use in
terms of creating them all right
and in here let me quickly create one
simple view so I'm going to add in so
I'm going to add in my state screw rules
and I'm going to add sales to my columns
and quickly create One bars audio all
right
foreign
let's say I want to analyze the uh sales
across each case here all right but I
also want to know the sound of distinct
items all right so in this case what I'm
going to do is let me have my product
name
all right because I want to know the
count of discount distinct items I'm
going to right click on the product name
here and I'm going to then drag and drop
this to the columns over here or right
onto the column section now because I've
selected the right click option and then
Dragged In dragged and dropped in the
product name or Dimension onto the
column it opens up the drop field as to
how I want to use it whether I want to
use since I want to use a distinct field
in analyzing all right it opened up this
particular window of whether I want to
use the count product name or account
distance product name all right so I'm
going to select the count distinct
because we want to distinctly analyze
the sounds of the items all right and
click on OK
all right uh what are aggregation
functions aggregation functions diksha
that's the sum the average these are the
different aggregation functions so right
now the basic default is sum all right
so it's summing up the major whatever
measure we've selected that's the
aggregation function so whether you want
to sum it up you want to average it out
you want to use median count minimum
maximum these are all the inbuilt
aggregation functions provided by
tableau or then you can also use the
aggregation functions when you're using
calculated C is beyond the ones provided
so those are aggregation functions
uh yes we have a bar chart I'm going to
still analyze and show these details to
you further in terms of aggregation so
what I did was instead of just using the
product name as it is I've used account
distinct all right uh could you please
drag and drop the product name or you
want me to show that to you once again
Shiva yes uh I'm gonna take this off my
uh columns here now when I want to add
my product name if I directly drag and
drop it onto the columns it's just going
to add up the details asking me how I
want to use it as a dimension now that's
not what I want to do because as per the
analysis I want to I want the count of
distinct items right so for that I'm
going to Simply right click on product
name and then I'm going to drag and drop
the product name onto the columns so in
that it's going to then ask me what is
the aggregation I want to use on my
dimension and I want to use the count
distance you can see count product name
and count distinct product name so I'm
selecting the second option and clicking
on OK
now I want to see the sales for item
sold and this particular field is not
available in my data set so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create uh
one using my calculated field because I
want to see the sales per item all right
so let me uh right click on my sales
here all right in the database one way
of doing it is you can right click on
the drop down you have the option of
clicking on create a calculated field
all right for that specific field or in
the data pane in the drop down here it
says create calculated field okay you
can select either option when you select
the drop down for you from here it's
blank and you'll have to input the
formula when you select a particular
field and do it then in that case it
opens up and adds in the field by
default wherein then you can specify the
functions and operators so let me
specify the arithmetic calculation here
so uh the first type that I'm showing
you the very first option in terms of
calculator see the arithmetic
calculation all right
so let's have our sum of sales
and
I'm going to divide this because I want
to know sales or item sold now that is
the reason I've created the crown
distinct product name here so Dexter
when you mentioned you're seeing two
bars the only reason I did that was
right now I'm just trying to create
account product name and once I add in
the details I'm then going to replace
the particular uh view from it all right
so I'm going to divide this with the
counts
product name
all right so that's how we are creating
our sales for item calculation using the
arithmetic calculation method sales for
iTunes so I'm dividing the sales